just to cover the night I heard ralph
was invited to Sal's party and he
skipped out on the bill it was a typical
Ralph thing he showed up late all food
was already on the table he started
eating from everyone's appetizers by the
way what is that I mean you order an
appetizer and people feel they didn't
yeah I mean what is it we all had
discussions beforehand yes we're gonna
get the calamari and split it like it
was all put up there before him right
and it's a fat guy you don't need
another person taking away your pork
well I might head I'm like okay we're
splitting this calamari four ways we're
splitting the fried ravioli three ways
okay I got it
what did you do I pulled your move where
you skipped out on the bill front I
don't want any [ __ ] I don't have
that move first of all I didn't skip out
I got there late cuz I was working with
you right so I got a salad and then the
bill came and everybody split it up it
was one hundred and fifty dollars and
have a hundred and fifty dollars with me
and I thought it was a lot for a salad
too you want to yeah so fifty but
whatever so you had pasta drinks
yeah a wine glass a wine yet parlor
salad and a side of pasta yeah a glass I
don't have much stuff is there so it was
like at the best fifty bucks with tip oh
yeah that's right but it wasn't that's
not the way what he would do I didn't
say I wasn't gonna pay I said I'm having
a conversation so the party's leaving
out though is when he showed up when
ralf showed up he immediately started
drinking the wine right started eating
everyone else's appetizers right right